eat SOT your car Chester Sasha cough is
about to put a Mercedes c-class through
its paces not this vintage model but the
new one but we do have time for a
comparison of old and new the 202 was
the first car to be called a
mercedes-benz c-class since 1993 the
c-class has been Mercedes smallest
rear-wheel drive model and a mid-range
flagship the car was available in a
variety of designs and with a variety of
option packages we're testing the
smallest package the S plea like a mine
Sasha says that as soon as he got in the
car he noticed how much room there was
but he says that maybe because the seats
are wider and have less side support
giving an impression of space um that's
when he didn't handle cuts that's my
main plot that we try out the 1996 C 180
with a 90 kilowatt four-cylinder engine
it goes from zero to one hundred and
twelve seconds which is pretty slow for
such a powerful engine back then the car
costs forty four thousand six hundred
twenty marks
FNZ nice Sasha says that car doesn't
drive badly but it does ask a lot more
of the driver than modern cars this
vehicle will qualify as a young timer in
seven years Kenan loin theta the Sasha
says the new c-class is a lot more
comfortable the seats are more
accommodating offer better side support
and are electronically adjustable
electronic locating that may be a
problem the car has a lot of electronics
including the entertainment system which
is operated by this wheel along with
touch pads and various buttons
in 20 years when this car is a young
timer it's hard to imagine that
everything will still work properly on
Tamotsu Vaden Avidan nozzle photos taken
from suit strategist visit starfighters
the new Mercedes C class has an
individually adjustable air ride system
a novelty in this category to improve
drivability Mercedes engineers put the
c-class on a diet the hood the hatchback
and the roof are all made of aluminum
Plus Lincoln Tina Sasha says that the
steering wheel is noticeably smaller and
more practical and the chassis is a lot
better the new c-class reacts
immediately whereas the old one was a
bit of a boat say closer the lightweight
materials in the best drag coefficient
in its class make the car very
fuel-efficient the 150 kilowatts e250
BlueTEC diesel model we tested consumes
only four point three liters of fuel per
100 kilometers carbon dioxide emissions
are low 109 grams per kilometer and the
car is a top speed of two hundred forty
seven kilometers an hour the car we
tested with the avant-garde option
package cost a bit over forty six
thousand euros in germany definitely
funciona Sansha says functions like
automatic trunks word around back in
1996 with full hands opening the back
when old c-class was tricky but the
trunk itself hardly changed the old
c-class had a 430 litre capacity and the
new one has just 50 liters more out of
my facility mia separate back seats were
optional in the old c-class whereas
their standard in the new one a few
things have changed the old c-class had
a classic grille well the new one has a
3d grille with a large mercedes star
but the traditional star in the hood is
gone the two cars hatchbacks are very
different but the characteristic
ornamental molding has been retained
you can still sense a lot of history in
the design of the new c-class the
interior of the old c-class was somewhat
cold and sterile a new one is more
inviting with its high quality materials
and bright colors the gearshift has been
replaced by a multimedia console and the
air vents which has given way to climate
control the old speedometer was very
easy to read
in the new model the on-board computer
does the job
Agnes de Sasha says that for him it's no
contest between the 1996 and 2014
c-class even the interior of the old car
wasn't really his thing so he prefers
the new generation the question is
whether you can afford a new car or
whether you have to settle for a good
used one in any case he's going to enjoy
taking the new model out for a drive if
you mind him fight adelphia find on the
one letting him knowing